Previously on startup. I started a company called not [inaudible]
, which is a platform to share 6.1 second videos. I have a rich nemesis called
Aria
who embarrassed me in a game of chess. I started to work on not fine. And then suddenly Aria
launched and returned before us allowing people to share 5.9 second videos.
You beat me to it, man. He launched Revine to,
for not buying what a sly man.
He knew exactly.
What he was doing and he just cut me off just like that.
And now I'm not the first anymore. It's crazy. Like, you know,
I don't even know why he asked to do that. I mean, it doesn't,
he have already enough money.
It's just crazy, man.
Like every time I feel like I hit a brick wall and then I get so close to what I
want and then boom, another brick wall.
It's frustrating.
Sometimes just feels like a, like a stupid game.
Like someone's looking over my shoulders, just like making a fool out of myself.
It's making me running around like an idiot
And that you're hungry, man. I kind of forgot you were here. Nah, I'm good.
Cool.
Do you ever feel like
We're part of a show or something like old obstacles?
We come up against this so hard. They seem like they're impossible,
but the very last second we always solve it.
It's like the Truman show with Jim Carey. Do you ever feel that way?
Nope. Not at all. I don't know what you're talking about.
Not even like a little bit.
You mean like imagine if this whole thing,
this whole situation that we're in is all just for a web series for like a
YouTube channel or something. Is that what you're saying? Yeah. Come on,
man. That's so silly and yeah, way too much imagination. I mean,
if we were a web series, it would be a pretty boring web series and worst thing.
[Inaudible]
which is why I think you are.
Definitely the best school to go to. Right.
Like get here. Um,
we were just outside and then we walked here. Yeah.
But what was the path that we keep from the
path? Dude? We just took the road. Yeah.
Okay. Whatever.
Come with me sandwiches. Oh gosh.
Yeah. Sure.
All right.
So let me tell you why Revit as a huge threat to our success,
it all comes down to marketing. Basically the perception of our brands.
Now nobody knows about non-fire, but everyone knows about Revit.
Suddenly he became the first mover and in marketing that is extremely important,
especially for a product like not fine or refined perception to be the
best is actually way more important to actually be the best. I mean,
let's say our servers can handle, you know,
way more requests and our UI slightly better. Does that make us the best? No,
not really.
Because in people's minds where you find what's the first looping video company,
hence the best company. And since they've launched before us,
they can brand themselves as whatever they want because the public will believe
them. Now let's take an example.
Think catch-up what company do you think makes the best ketchup Heinz.
Exactly hindsight, but that's because there were first movers.
That's what you think they're the best. Now you're thinking about it.
Who do you think the second company is for? Catch-ups exactly. You don't know.
Nobody cares. Nobody cares when your second,
everyone only cares when you're at first.
So same thing for Jack Daniel's for whiskey and like Tesla for electric cars.
That's why we need to be the first for the looping videos, but we're not.
So basically now people think of looping videos. They'll think of Revine,
not non-client that's because they are the market leader.
And no matter what we can't be first anymore, however,
not all is lost though.
We can not be first in the looping video sharing platform.
We can try to be first and something else.
Basically we have to avoid the competition and come up with our own product
category. Here's an example. IBM used to be the leading company for computers.
Right. But then other companies wanted to get in on the action.
Like have you heard of borough control data NCR or Sperry.
Shoe company? No, I'm talking about computers right now.
Why would I talk about shoes?
Those were companies that want to make computers.
Also the only one who succeeded and often called the second largest computer
company was DEC, why were they successful?
Because they weren't competing in the computer market.
They were competing in the microcomputers.
So they were the first microcomputer product category.
What happened to the other companies?
Those other companies were too focused on getting people to like their brand,
which is extremely hard by the way,
because once a perception is made by a person it's really hard to change their
minds.
What they should have done is to try to think of a category that tick a thrive
on and be first that people don't give a what's better.
They care about what's new. So here's my proposal in new category,
we are going to make for our non looping videos on our platform
for hours changes. That was a joke.
But yeah, and I just haven't thought about anything yet, but I mean,
we have to pivot that TECO drive will really the number on us,
all the VCs, every engineer, they all know about Revit.
Everyone in the Valley knows about Revit. Yeah.
I mean, we basically lost her first mover advantage.
Wait, everyone in the Valley knows about it.
Wait, was it only tech question on what about it? Yeah.
When we tech folks wrote about it, dude, nobody in the family makes videos.
Only tech nerds know about Revit. Revit is first in the minds of engineers,
but during all their target.
So we're not too late to be the first in the minds of creators and social media.
[Inaudible].
You know,
always want to weird like why on a boat?
If you keep a dock here the whole time, it's like, you're trapped.
You're forever kind of like us. Right. Wait, what do you mean?
I didn't say anything.
[Inaudible].
You know, if you want to try owning a boat, I got this great game.
Boating simulator. Got it. Try it. It's really realistic.
It's really realistic.
Path.
Sandwiches kind of like us, right?
[Inaudible].
Hey Dom, can I talk to you for a sec? Yeah, what's up?
So I ran the simulation. You're asking me to and not by one.
Yeah. Um, they're not fine. One.
We've got the preliminary results of the experiment and it looks like the
success rate is only about 17% should be terminated.
Now let's keep it running. There's always a chance to metrics will increase.
How are the other simulations going? Well,
some of the other seem promising like vitally and vine book.
I continued to report and highlight the features that are most predictive of our
success. That'll be great, but let's keep an eye on that.
Not by I'm really curious how it ends.
It might just tell us the perfect launch strategy
what's popping April 4th, everybody. So yeah. Uh, we are not in assimilation.
This episode is not part of the Canon, so don't worry about that.
So I just want to say, um, thank you for watching this episode. If you liked it,
if you like it, don't forget to subscribe. And then also like this video.
Thank you so much. Uh, just a little bit announcement.
I am going to take a break on the startup series. I'm going to skip episode six.
So instead of doing it next month, I'm going to do it next next month. Uh,
sorry about that,
but I need to take a break and the reason why I'm taking a break is actually
because I want to make more videos and these videos take a long time and I kind
of want to try to make two videos a week for the next month.
A lot of exciting stuff that I'm going to do.
So hopefully you're going to enjoy the content I'll put out later. But yeah,
so of course start-up series.
You're going to have to wait a little bit for that. Thanks.